y
[Música]
en eeuu el partido demócrata avanza de
la puesta en marcha de un juicio
político relámpago contra el presidente
saliente de donald trump a 11 días entre
su salida de la casa blanca- trump se
encuentra aislado políticamente en medio
de una hora de renuncias en su gabinete
y con su principal megáfono su cuenta de
twitter cancela
la organización mundial de la salud hizo
un nuevo llamado a los gobiernos de los
países ricos a no saltarse la fila de
compras bilaterales de vacunas con talco
y 19 en contraste la unión europea
compró 300 millones de dosis más del
fármaco desarrollado por facer y by un
tec
al menos dos personas han muerto según
las autoridades a causa de la intensa
nevada que se vive en el centro de
españa tirada por la tormenta filomena y
que ha ocasionado problemas de movilidad
terrestre y aérea expertos aseguran que
la nevada más fuerte en los últimos 60
años en la capital española
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y el mundo aquí en real 24
bienvenidos nuevamente mi nombre es
liviana valencia iniciamos en eeuu donde
los congresistas demócratas buscan
activar un impeachment o juicio político
en contra del presidente saliente de
donald trump a quienes planean acusar de
incitar a la insurrección según algunos
medios del país la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes nancy pelosi
dijo que procederá a si trump no
renuncia de manera inmediata e informó
que ha hablado con altos mandos
militares para restringir el acceso de
trump a código son nucleares
hace cerca de 50 años después de años de
contemporizar con su presidente rebelde
los republicanos en el congreso
finalmente le dijeron al presidente
nixon que era hora de irse hoy después
de los peligrosos y sediciosos actos del
presidente los republicanos en el
congreso necesitan seguir ese ejemplo y
llamar a choam para dejar su cargo de
inmediato si el presidente no deja su
oficina de inmediato y voluntariamente
el congreso procederá con nuestra acción
donald trump ha perdido el apoyo de
muchos de sus colaboradores e
integrantes de su propio partido cuando
faltan 11 días para que abandone la casa
blanca el mandatario está aislado y
además las plataformas facebook y
twitter suspendieron sus cuentas
personales por incitar a la violencia y
el asalto al capitolio el pasado 6 de
enero
esto es lo que queda de la cuenta del
presidente de donald trump twitter tomó
la decisión de suspenderla
permanentemente argumentando que hay
riesgo de una mayor incitación a la
violencia el mandatario es señalado de
alentar a sus seguidores a tomarse el
capitolio un episodio que dejó un saldo
de cinco muertos dejamos en claro hace
años que estas cuentas no están por
encima de nuestras reglas y no pueden
usar twitter para incitar a la violencia
de acuerdo con twitter dos de los
últimos tuits de trump infringen sus
políticas de admiración a la violencia
antes la compañía solo se había limitado
a etiquetar u ocultar sus tweets por ser
un funcionario gubernamental había
estado exento de ser vetados de la
plataforma al considerar que su
contenido es de interés público pero
twitter también deja claro que esto no
significa que cualquier funcionario
público es elegible para tuitear lo que
quiera especialmente cuando el riesgo de
daño es mayor o más severo a través de
la cuenta oficial de la presidencia
trump refutó las medidas pero sus
publicaciones fueron eliminadas
creo que las acciones del presidente el
miércoles mostró al mundo el peligro de
mantener el control de este mecanismo de
medio social hay que recordar el donald
trump casi inventó el estilo de liderar
un país por twitter con más de 88
millones de seguidores twitter era la
red social favorita del presidente
emitía decenas de trinos diarios y había
utilizado su cuenta para anunciar sus
decisiones e incluso despedir a sus
funcionarios
trump aún tiene acceso a las cuentas de
la casa blanca y de la presidencia pero
lo perderá cuando finalice su mandato el
20 de enero un portavoz de la compañía
advirtió que cualquier cuenta que sea
creada para evadir la suspensión también
sería eliminada
cambiamos de información porque la
organización mundial de la salud hizo un
llamado a los países de mayores recursos
a no saltarse la fila en la adquisición
de la vacuna contra el coronavirus ya
contribuir a que las naciones más
vulnerables tengan acceso a ella esto
cuando la unión europea anunció que
duplicará su orden de vacunas the
fighter iv by on dec
que nadie se salte la pila para las
vacunas con esa advertencia la
organización mundial de la salud instó a
los países de mayores recursos a dejar
de firmar acuerdos directos con las
productoras y permitir que naciones de
menores ingresos accedan a las
inmunizaciones mediante el mecanismo
solidario cobats wing voz de marilyn cam
acá estamos viendo a países de ingresos
altos y medios que son parte de kóvacs a
alcanzar acuerdos bilaterales
adicionales potencialmente esto eleva el
precio para todos y significa que las
personas de mayor riesgo en los países
más pobres y vulnerables no obtienen la
vacuna el nacionalismo de la vacuna nos
hiere a todos y es contraproducente old
and self déficit según la o ms 42 países
han iniciado la vacunación 36 de altos
recursos y 6 de medios mientras que el
proceso no ha comenzado en ninguna
nación pobre por eso el organismo instó
a quienes tienen más dosis de las
necesarias a donarlas al programa cobats
un llamado que contrasta con el anuncio
de la unión europea que duplicó su
pedido a facer variante que así pasará
de 300 a 600 millones de dosis es decir
casi la mitad de la producción
tal de esa alianza para 2021 de momento
es la única en circulación en el bloque
a la espera de la distribución de las
180 millones de dosis adquiridas a
moderna which is you is right tronistas
dos vacunas autorizadas ya hemos
asegurado una cantidad de dosis
necesaria para vacunar a 380 millones de
europeos esto es más del 80 por ciento
de la población europea modern age
percent of the years in college la
contracara es áfrica donde los altos
precios y las condiciones de
conservación a temperaturas bajas han
supuesto problemas para adquirir las
vacunas una situación que aprovecha
china para expandir su influencia en el
continente prometiendo entregar su
vacuna a las naciones de menores
recursos
américa latina' de peso del 2021 en
medio de fuertes repuntes de contagios
hospitalizaciones y muertes causadas por
el cob y 19 méxico reportó un nuevo
récord de casos en las últimas 24 horas
superando los 14.000 y colombia registró
la cifra más alta de contagios desde el
inicio de la pandemia con más de 18 mil
200 contagios ambas naciones se acercan
al 90% de ocupación en las unidades de
cuidados intensivos los gobiernos
aplican nuevas restricciones y hay temor
por la presidencia de la nueva variante
del patógeno en la región
vamos ahora al centro de españa donde se
registra la nevada más intensa los
últimos 60 años según las autoridades al
menos dos personas perdieron la vida a
causa de la emergencia una capa de medio
metro de nieve cubre las calles
residencias y lugares públicos de madrid
ocasionando estragos a la movilidad
terrestre y aérea y preocupación por la
vida de las personas sin hogar servicios
de emergencia trabajan para rescatar a
decenas de personas atrapadas en este
momento estamos centrados en el rescate
de conductores que están atrapados en
distintos puntos de la comunidad de
madrid' en distintos puntos kilométricos
con el objetivo de ponerles en zona
segura para ello se ha activado toda la
capacidad del cuerpo de bomberos de la
comunidad de madrid' del cuerpo bomberos
de la ciudad de madrid' y también se ha
solicitado la intervención de la unidad
militar de emergencias para colaborar en
nuestras tareas que ahora mismo son las
prioritarias la ola de frío que invade
europa hace aún más duras las
condiciones en las que al menos 1.300
migrantes siguen a la intemperie en la
localidad bosnia del ipa el pasado 23 de
diciembre el campo donde se albergaban
sufrió un incendio
a la salida de la organización
internacional para las migraciones
veamos este informe de adán díaz
un infierno en la nieve para miles de
emigrantes más de un millar de personas
quedaron desamparadas después de que las
llamas acabarán con el campamento de
refugiados el 23 de diciembre
ahora la nieve empeora su situación
cruise ya en selvin ya croacia y
eslovenia por favor les rogamos que nos
den una oportunidad de ir hacia italia
wang ywen chance en bosnia la vida es
peligrosa todos estos inmigrantes están
en una situación realmente mala en
bosnia
el cual es gay ver sitio de gentes las
autoridades planeaban relocalizar a los
migrantes en el municipio de veras dina
a 320 km mientras se formaban las
instalaciones pero el acuerdo nunca
llegó y tuvieron que quedarse esperando
en la fría intemperie la policía bosnia
cree que fueron algunos migrantes
quienes incendiaron el campamento como
forma de protesta por las condiciones
del mismo y por la retirada de la
organización internacional para las
migraciones
ahora mi casa está quemada este
campamento es mi casa todos los
alojamientos están quemados no tenemos
en ningún tipo de instalación
yo estoy durmiendo en los baños muchas
personas tienen enfermedades y no hay ni
medicinas ni doctores y hospitales
scripts inc
según fuentes oficiales la remodelación
de la infraestructura el lipa comenzará
aunque no será hasta abril se estima que
unos 10.000 migrantes de asia oriente
medio y el norte de áfrica han quedado
atrapados en bosnia camino de países
europeos más ricos
así finalizamos en el 24 pero los
invitamos a continuar como hacen nuestra
página web trans 24 puntos como
información en cuatro idiomas para
ustedes quédense con nosotros
[Música]